bonjour mon cher jeanud est-ce que vous
connaissez FRAC pro shooter mais pas du
tout et bien FRAC pro shooter est un FPS
spécialement conçu pour mobile jouez
avec plus d'un million de joueurs
quotidiens créez votre Deck et
construisez votre propre stratégie pour
détruire les bâtiments adverses
détruisez les bunkers et les tours de
vos ennemis le plus rapidement possible
massacrez vos ennemis jusqu'au dernier
et brûler leur
famille
plus de 90 personnages à collectionner
avec leur gameplay et pouvoirs spécifiqu
et maintenant découvrez le nouveau
personnage sunny il peut placer des
pièges holographiques presque invisibles
qui étourdissent les ennemis autour de
lui dans la zone jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
détruit des pièges qui détruisent des
ennemis holographiques dans une zone
presque invisible jusqu'à ce qu' est
détruite lien en description récupère
des ressources gratuites même pour ceux
qui ont déjà installé frag un coffre en
or 500 pièces d'or ainsi que 50 diamants
pour une valeur de 7 € waouh le cour de
lors et du diamant a vachement baissé
jeu disponible sur tablette et
mobile salut à tous vous êtes sur le
point de regarder la prochaine vidéo JDG
dans sa version censurée si vous en avez
la possibilité je vous invite donc très
sérieusement à aller regarder la version
réservée au plus de 18 ans qui elle ne
comporte aucune censure et je vous dis
ça alors que cette version 18 plus
pourtant sera évidemment démonétisé et
ne nous rapportera pas un centime à part
le sponsor bien sûr alors je n'en veux
absolument pas à la modération française
he qui ne fait que appliquer la
politique dictée depuis les États-Unis
mais la censure a atteint un degré de
stupidité tel qu'on nous a demandé de
biper des mots comme fesses ou pisser de
la même manière dans leur politique
absurde les femmes sont parfois
considéré comme du contenu sexuel donc
vous verrez que dans cette vidéo il y a
des passages plusieurs passages même où
il y a des femmes qui sont floutées ou
pixelisées ou censurées alors qu'elles
sont pourtant total habillé alors je
sais pas si c'est du puritanisme à
outrance ou si dans leur tête malade ils
pensent protéger les femmes en faisant
ça mais le résultat est le même c'est
qu'on se retrouve avec une politique de
censure digne du pire des régimes
taliban donc voilà he comme pour
cyberpunk cette vidéo sera divisée en
deux parties une vidéo réservée au plus
de 18 ans qui n'est pas censurée et une
vidéo accessible à tout le monde qui
sera censurée et je pense que ce genre
de chose va se multiplier pour nous à
l'avenir puisque il semblerait que
YouTube vous considère tous comme des
enfants s d'une crèche mon avis
personnel c'est que par sa politique de
censure qui ne se cache même plus en
fait YouTube essaie de pousser vers la
sortie tout ce qui n'est pas ce fameux
contenu tendance friendly good vibe que
j'affectionne tant vous le savez
sincèrement j'ai atteint un degré de
dégoût envers cette plateforme qui est
telle que même en sachant qu'il s'agit
de notre principale source de revenu je
lui souhaite de crever franchement tout
tout simplement parce que produire du
contenu avec un commissaire politique
qui regarde par-dessus ton épaule en
permanence pour te dire ce que tu as le
droit de dire ou de pas
dire pour moi c'est juste plus de la
création en fait voilà ben sur ce donc
je vous souhaite quand même un bon
visionnage et j'espère que ça vous
plaira malgré
[Musique]
tout
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 salut à tous si je vous dis FPS vous
me dites le jeu de tir à la première
personne ou en anglais FPS est un genre
de jeu vidéo de tir fondé sur des
combats de vision subjective
c'est-à-dire que le joueur voit l'action
à travers les yeux du protagoniste non
non je voulais dire me citer un FPS ah
oui
Mario
2 non bien sûr vous allez me citer Doom
tout le monde connaît un jeu de tir à la
première personne où on désingue des
monstres par centaine s Gor violant il y
a du sang il y a des boyaux d'ailleurs
pendant longtemps les FPS ne
s'appelaient pas des FPS justement mais
des dooml Doom c'est un peu le père de
tous les FPS c'est pas Wolfenstein si
mais vu que si j'en parle on va se faire
démonétiser on va dire que c'est Doom
mais avant d'aller plus loin revenons un
peu en arrière parce que que ce soit
pour parler de Doom ou de Duke du Kem je
ne peux pas commencer sans évoquer le
modèle du shareware lorsque Scott Miller
le futur producteur des Duke Nukem cré
sa société à poog il a recours à un
système original le shareware le
shareware c'est qu'en gros ton jeu est
divisé en plusieurs parties et
d'ailleurs tu as même le droit de le
copier pour le refiler à tous tes potes
mais par contre si tu as aimé ça et que
tu veux la suite bah là il va falloir
racker et vous savez qui d'autre
applique ce système les vendeurs de
crack
euh j'allais dire les jeux mobiles mais
les deux réponses sont valides ce modèle
est un succès total avec aucun
intermédiaire Scott Miller récolte
presque 100000 balles la première année
en distribuant son jeu Kingdom of
Crow ouais Salz beau très vite il laisse
tomber la programmation et recrute des
petits nouveaux pour bosser à sa place
pojet devient alors à la fois éditeur et
développeur de jeux vidéo et les
nouveaux venus vont l'aider à créer leur
nouveau héros un certain du Nukem ah
pardon c'est pas lui oui alors du Nukem
à la base c'est censé être le nom d'un
personnage de Captain Planet sauf que
ben du coup ils ont flippé de se prendre
un procès au cul et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont renommé leur version 2.0 en
Duke
newum attendez une seconde je me
souviens de vous c'était vous Bitman je
ne travaille toujours pas ici
sauf que manque de bol pour captaine
planette et bien le nom du méchant
n'était pas déposé et c'est pour ça que
Duke Nukem a pu de nouveau s'appeler
Duke Nukem dans les jeux suivants et
justement le troisème opus de Duke Nukem
est en préparation et contrairement aux
deux premiers qui étaient des
plateformeur celui-ci sera un doom like
il fera même mieux que Doom puisque le
moteur de Duke Nukem 3D permettra à Duke
de nager voler en jetpack regarder en
haut et en bas chose qui était
impossible dans Doom et même détruire
des éléments du décor mais évidemment
c'est surtout le côté beau desclex c'est
du personnage qui fera parler du jeu le
personnage est violent vulgaire sale
sexiste misogyne c'est normal donc que
ce soit un énorme
succès cette phrase va encore me valoir
des problèmes d 97 la suite de Duke 3D
est annoncé en grande pompe et le jeu
s'appellera Duke newukem Forever un
titre calqué sur Batman
Forever déjà ils ont construit leur jeu
sur un cimetière indien ça partait mal
et Duke Nukem Forever vous avez
forcément entendu ce nom au moins une
fois c'est une célébrité du jeu vidéo un
des plus grands échecs les galères
commencent lorsque George Broussard
vice-président d'apoget se retrouve seul
à la tête du navire suite à la démission
de son collègue Tod replogel il opte
tout d'abord pour le moteur de Quake 1
avant de changer en cours de route pour
celui de Quake 2 pour la jolie somme
d'un demiillion de dollars et il déclare
screenshot à la pque Duke du Kem Forever
sera le plus beau jeu de
1998 et en quelle année il est sorti le
jeu en 2011 à le 398 un trailer provoque
l'hystérie des fans la sortie du jeu est
imminente sauf que la fin des années 9
c'est aussi une période où la
technologie évolue très vite dans le jeu
vidéo et comme brousard a promis le
meilleur jeu du monde et bien il demande
constamment à ses équipes d'ajouter de
nouvelles futur et comme tout ça prend
du temps et bien le jeu prend du retard
et le moteur 3D devient obsolète c'est
marrant ça me rappelle Star City oui Seb
à quoi ça te fait penser et c'est la
raison de l'échec de ce jeu ce cycle va
se répéter pendant des années unril sort
brousar é pououflé du coup dukeukem
Forever va passer à l'unry engine mais
vous vous souvenez du demimillion de
dollars de Quake 2 poubelle puis après
c'est Half Life qui sort et là brousard
veut la même intro pour son jeu puis
après c'est the sing qui se passe dans
la neige et là du coup Broussard veut un
niveau dans la neige ok les gars ce ci
c'est bon j'ai réglé le problème il nous
ennuiera
plus allô les gars je suis dans un
coffre on m'a enlevé ça serait super que
dans le jeu le héros se fasse
enlever 3 2001 parmi le milliard
d'annonces complètement fol de cette
année nouveau trailer pour Duke ducem
Forever et entre-temps leur éditeur GT
interactive qui se sont fait d'abord
racheter par infogramme puis revendre à
take to se permettent de communiquer
dans la presse sur l'hypothétique sortie
du jeu communication auquel Broussard
répondra il ferait mieux de fermer leur
[ __ ] de gueule le jeu il sera fini
quand il sera
fini qu'est-ce que tu fais oh pardon je
nettoy la souffleuse pendant ce temps-là
côté ses développements brusard vient de
décider de changer de moteur physique
pour concurrencer celui d'Alf Life 2 50
développement et on repart à zéro à
partir de 2005 plus de trailers plus de
screenshot la communication du jeu se
transforme en un silence gênant et de
toute façon les gens sont passés à autre
chose hein plus personne n'attend
duuknukem quand en face tu as
Battlefield ou Call of Duty en 2006 le
développement du jeu est reboé pour la
6e fois ce coup-ci sans n trro le tiers
de l'équipe des mission et 3 D rilms
ferme ses portes en mai 2009 duuk Nukem
Forever rentre alors dans l'histoire
comme la légende du vaporware ou en
français un
[Musique]
fumiciel tout ça aurait pu et même
aurait dû s'arrêter là mais un des
anciens de tris des rilms Randy
peachford devenu entre-temps président
de Gearbox que vous connaissez tous pour
borderland réussira par un tour de passp
juridique et financier à récupérer le
jeu en secret et finalement le jeu
sortira en 2011 après 14 années de
développement
et et c'est vraiment pas bien non le jeu
s'ouvre sur Duke votre personnage qui
allez on se bouge le cul tout le monde
veut voir Duke et son gros calibre en
action bon ben moi je vais m'en aller je
pense qu'on aura pas besoin de moi
aujourd'hui il a l'air bien ce jeu voilà
donc c'est littéralement la première
image que vous voyez de ce jeu un
urinoir avec un bouton sur laquelle il y
a marqué pisser d'ailleurs vous pouvez
aussi attraper du caca dans les
toilettes puis ensuite jeter le caca sur
les murs pour en repeindre la surface
avec du caca Quand tu es dans la merde
tu es dans la merde ça se confirme ok
donc JDG à côté c'est du Shakespeare le
jeu commence en réalité juste avant la
fin de Duke duem 3D vous affrontez un
énorme monstre dans un stade qui est le
même que vous devez battre à la fin de
Duke 3D vous le battez vous arracheer sa
tête et bam vous transformez l'essai
titre du
jeu qu'est-ce que je fais je bois même
pas d'alcool moi mais en fait tout ça
n'était que trom prix vous étiez en
réalité en train de jouer à un jeu vidéo
pendant
que c'était marrant tu as pris ton pied
chéri qu'est-ce que
font me refont les lacés ad B ben j'ai
deux chaussures qu'est-ce que tu as
pensé du jeu di tu as trouvé ça bon
ouais encore heureux [ __ ] après 12 ans
ouis même la blague elle est en retard
de 2 ans en tout cas si tu veux en jouer
c'est où tu veux quand tu
veux ok donc vous l'aurez compris dans
ce jeu nous avons assez peu de chance de
trouver des femmes diplômées en
astrophysique alors entendons-nous he
dans duc 3D on pouvait déjà filer un
billet à des stripteasus pour avoir
droit à la technique du moulin bulgare
et bon c'était un peu beau ça pouvait
faire sourire mais au moins les femmes
dans du 3D ell parlaient pas et c'était
mieux je vais reformuler ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que au moins dans Duke
3D le fait que les personnages féminins
ne parlaient pas ça permettait d'éviter
de montrer qu'elles étaient connes comme
des Ballé oh mon dieu merci vous êtes un
tireur exceptionnel je suis à vous quand
vous voulez oh là là je m'en fiche qu'il
soit petit moi je sais où je me le
mettrai je suis célibataire donc alors
les deux filles que vous voyez là sont
les jumelles hson qui sont évidemment
une parodie des jumelles Hsen ce qui est
un peu bizarre puisque en 2011 quand le
jeu est sorti cela faisait déjà bien
longtemps qu'elles avaient arrêté leur
carrière télévisuelle ce qui veut dire
qu'il s'agit d'une parodie d'elle à la
fin des années 90 au moment où elles
étaient âgé
de
[Musique]
bref souvenez-vous que je vous avais
parlé du fait que brousard voulait une
intro à la half comme quand Gordon
Freeman visite le centre de Black ma
bien le début du jeu c'est exactement ça
on se balade dans son immeuble en
touchant un petit peu à tout on regarde
les uvres d'art on écoute les dialogue
des P après l'émission vous pourrez
signer ma
ENF
enfyz quoi mais quoi j'ai besoin de
savoir on signe des autographes à ces
jeunes fans passionnés non c'est
dégueulasse je crois que j'ai déjà fait
ça en vrai ou encore on achète des
clopes dans le
[Musique]
distributeur ça va pas ou quoi ne dis
jamais ça à voix haute sur Youtube on a
même droit à des priv Jok comme cette
scène qui est une parodie de Christian
Bell qui s'énerve sur le tournage de
Terminator Renaissance bref les
développeurs se sont fait plaisir sur
cette partie et c'est un peu rigolo
notamment grâce à la qualité de
l'écriture
boou alors c'est qui le plus fort c'est
de la poésie à mes oreilles bref trè
rapidement les aliens se mettent à
attaquer la ville et c'est là où le vrai
jeu va commencer et ben c'est plutôt pas
ouf en fait le cœur du gameplay eff
fooiré on a des murs invisibles partout
un système d'endurance qui essouffle ton
personnage quand il court et surtout la
plus grosse critique qui a été faite à
ce jeu c'est que Duke est limité à deux
armes maximum ce qui castre complètement
le côté bourrin du jeu alors que c'était
l'essence même de ce qui avait fait le
succès de Duk ducem 3D ce côté je me
balade partout j'ai plein d'armes
j'explose de l'alien par centaine à la
place maintenant donc on a un système de
deux armes repompées d'ailleurs sur Allo
ce qui est assez ironique parce que le
jeu se permet justement de lâcher une
crotte sur à l'O un peu plus loin on
vous a apporté votre belle armure verte
si vous la voulez les armures c'est pour
lesouses après vous connaissez
l'expression hein la paille la poutre
l'hôpital la charité l'œuf la poule Eric
et Ramsy après je vais être clair he le
jeu n'est pas mauvais c'est juste un FPS
complètement générique du début des
années 2010 comme il y en a eu des
dizaines et en fait s'il y avait pas eu
tout ce foin au niveau du développement
et la licence du gukem ben c'est
typiquement le genre de jeu dont
personne n'aurait parlé en fait alors
c'est pas mauvais hein mais c'est juste
que ça marche pas bien on a un système
d'ego pour remonter sa barre de vie
parce que ouais duuk il a pas de barre
de vie he il a une barre d'ego et pour
regagner de Lego il faut soulever des
poids ou jouer au flippeurs c'est
l'heure de Beutter des cul et d'ailleurs
le jeu est rempli de messages éducatifs
ah ben tu vois Jonathan que j'avais
raison alors maintenant tu arrêtes de
faire l'enfant et tu bois ta bière on a
même des passages plutôt intéressants
dans le jeu on a des phases de gameplay
où notre personnage est rétréci comme
dans Duke 3D des phases où on va
contrôler une petite voiture
télécommandée ou même monter dedans des
phases de shoot en position fixe des QTE
et pas mal de minijeux d'une manière
générale qui sont plutôt fun
bon après on a tous une notion
différente de ce qui est fun par exemple
Sébastien moi je fais des petites chaise
en bouchon de champagne voilà ça c'est
fun par contre passer 1h30 à essayer de
faire un saut dans une phase de voiture
épouvantable mais genre vraiment j'ai un
[ __ ] de disque dur entier d'image sur
ce passage là ça c'est pas fun et ça
rend fou hein et d'ailleurs en plus je
me suis soft lock là [ __ ] mais quel
enfer je te jure là je suis bloqué voilà
c'est c'est c'est cuit là ma voiture
elle s'est retournée voilà je suis comme
une tortue sur le dos bah c'est mort
allez plus qu'à recharger la sauvegarde
vive le gaming bon alors après je vais
pas vous montrer chaque niveau du jeu
parce que encore une fois ça n'aurait
aucun intérêt la plupart des niveaux
sont comme j'ai dit un espèce de FPS
générique sans â que tu as l'impression
d'avoir déjà vu 1000 fois et finalement
en fait les seuls niveaux qu'on va
retenir c'est ceux qui
sont
différent alors ce niveau s'appelle la
ruche je ne peux pas vraiment vous le
montrer sans faire fermer cette chaîne
mais je peux vous le décrire alors ça
c'est maman ça c'est les extraterrestres
et oh
[Applaudissements]
non mais sérieusement mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe ici on dirait que je viens de
trouver la collection de Nai personnel
du mec qui a fait le design de alien et
oui je sais que le scénare dans Duk
Nukem ça a toujours été ça les
extraterrestres qui viennent pour
enlever les femmes sauf que dans les
années 90 les graphismes étaient
tellement primaires que c'était
difficile de prendre ça au sérieux mais
là avec les graphismes de 2011 la
frontière entre la blague et le fétiche
bizarre devient un peu flou tenez donc
par exemple genre pour avancer dans ce
niveau de la ruche il faut les portes
qui sont en forme quel trou
du et je vous ai montré ce niveau qui
est horrible et encore je vous montre
pas tout mais il y a un autre passage
gloissime dans une salle de strip alors
je suis désolé pourensure mais là
vraiment j'ai pas le choix o on doit
récupérer divers items tel des
popcorn un cigare
et Rin Doig vous notez que je fais
vraiment des effort là on aura droit
aussi à divers passages avec des action
contextuelles qui permettront
d'augmenter sa barre
d' il y avait qui de l'autre
côté
oups et après une série de niveaux tous
plus ennuyeux les uns que les autres le
jeu se termine par un boss fight ou
après l'avoir vaincu vous lui dans la
bouche des
questions le monde entier saluera la
médiocrité du jeu et après une si longue
attente la déception sera forcément
immense l'édition collector nommée balls
of steel ENF je veux dire c'est
dégueulasse et le marketing incroyable
comme avec ce mini jeu flash intitulé
dukeem qui servait d'outil
promotionnel auront quand même réussi
l'exploit de rembourser les années de
développement chez gearbox le jeu est
donc
rentable et [ __ ] c'est pas rien parce
que la vache il partait de loin mais du
Forever restera surtout dans l'histoire
pour son développement chaotique ce qui
est aussi finalement la raison pour
laquelle j'ai passé plus de temps à vous
parler de la création du jeu que du jeu
en lui-même on peut blam Broussard
d'avoir gâché le projet trop coûteux
trop ambitieux mais en même temps tout
ce qu'il voulait c'était juste faire le
meilleur jeu du monde alors est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment lui en vouloir pour ça
Duke qu'est-ce qui nous arrive et ben
vous êtes [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui